An average adult human mouth contains
32 teeth.
The agreed definition of a tooth
is a highly mineralised
unit within the mouth.
Thirty-two highly mineralised units,
eight incisors, four canines,
eight premolars and eight molars.
Plus four wisdom teeth which don’t
tend to make themselves known
until about five years after the
rest of the adult set are in place,
because of course these 32 teeth
are your second set.
An average baby is born
with both milk and adult teeth
already in their head.
A seven-year-old Indian boy was
recently found to have 526 teeth
inside his mouth.
But let's stick to the more common
number. 20 milk teeth, 32 adult,
a total of 52.
Fifty-two teeth, rarely visible
when born but they're all there,
in the skull.
Waiting...
waiting...
to erupt!
Thank goodness we can't remember
teething. Consider if you will the
brutality of these shards of enamel
ripping through innocent gums.
No wonder babies cry.
Reward for this discomforting
experience comes when that first set
of baby teeth start to fall out,
ready for the tooth fairy.
The first recording of such a
transaction with a fee being paid
for a child's lost tooth
is in 13th Century Norse culture.
Vikings going into battle
would wear necklaces
made up of children's teeth.
Not because it presumably
looked utterly terrifying,
but because they were
considered lucky.
In the UK, the most common
price paid for a tooth is £1,
although 11% of children
apparently sleep soundly
with a crisp fiver under their
pillow - far less lumpy than a coin.
Children in the Middle Ages were
sometimes instructed to burn
their baby teeth, or risk spending
the afterlife searching for them...
With such historical scaremongering
surrounding teeth, it is perhaps
easier to understand why so many
people now have a fear of dentists.
Eighty-four per cent of all adults
in the UK have at least one filling
and the average Brit has seven.
Of course fillings are just
one dental procedure,
your teeth may also be cleaned,
flossed, capped or crowned,
bonded, braced, sealed,
whitened or extracted.
But just remember, that going to the
dentist today is far less precarious
than it used to be.
Before dentistry found acceptance
as a medical profession,
extraction was the domain
of barbers and blacksmiths.
Essentially, anyone with access
to sharp tools or heavy pliers.
As 19th Century dentists like
Horace Wells and William Morton
struggled to be considered
professionals rather than tradesman,
public demonstrations of painless
tooth extractions became
more and more commonplace.
Some using nitrous oxide ended in
a volunteer screaming in agony,
but by 1846, dentistry had
finally cracked anaesthesia.
People attempt to please their
dentists by brushing their teeth,
a practice that has evolved from
twigs and leaves, into a global
toothpaste industry worth billions.
Human teeth are now primarily used
for biting off strips of sticky tape.
But these highly mineralised rocks
are also responsible for crushing,
slicing and making manageable
almost every meal or snack
you'll ever enjoy.
But we also use them
to reflect our mood to others,
be that a welcoming smile
or an aggressive snarl.
Contemporary teeth can be
adorned with jewelled grilles
or filtered to perfection
on Instagram,
but to think of the all-white
uniform smile as perfect
is a relatively recent obsession.
Having a varied set of teeth is what
allowed humans to survive
and flourish across the globe.
Our teeth have evolved to incorporate
varying diets and environments,
frankly, we're lucky to have them.
Alligator teeth are considered
particularly lucky.
But if you're seeking dental
inspiration, look no further than...
sharks.
Unlike us, sharks can afford to loose
a few teeth as they're able
to regenerate and replace
them almost continuously.
One great white shark can produce
tens of thousands of teeth
in their lifetime,
which makes our 52 seem relatively...
toothless.